Joining me today is an author,
a professor in evolutionary behavioral
scientist,
a man who wears a bow tie when speaking
to the Canadian parliament and a guy
with an incredible tan,
Gaad Saad.
Welcome back to the Rubin report.
So nice to be back.
Thanks Dave.
The Tan,
I don't know that our cameras,
I don't know the new tube through the
wires and the tubes or whatever.
It gets it out to the people.
I don't know that it can take that level
of 10.
They're just you being next to me.
You're going to get that?
I hope so because I've never felt whiter
than I feel right now.
That is that good Lebanese skin that you
had as A.
Alright,
so you've been on the show many times.
You were my.
My first year on the first test show of
the Rubin report.
You were on the first panel we ever did.
We've done one on ones a couple times
from getting to know you.
You have just been in sort of what I
would call the fight that is happening
now.
The free speech fight,
the fight for enlightenment values for
liberal values.
The whole thing,
uh,
but I thought a nice way to start would
be you would happen to be on vacation
right now,
right?
You were in the midst of a five weeks,
so cal vacation.
And how important is that when you are
someone that puts yourself out there all
the time?
As I said,
you just spoke to Canadian parliament.
You were at Google doing a talk.
I mean just as someone that's always out
there.
The shutdown.
How important.
Very important.
Although I am,
I've done a few shows while I'm here,
so there's a bit of work interspersed
within the vacation.
It's terribly important.
Not so much for going to the beach,
but for disconnecting from being
available to the public now.
I always promised my wife that I will
absolutely not check a single social
media and then usually that lasts three,
four,
five days and then I succumb to the
temptation,
but that I think is fundamentally the
most important part of my vacation,
which is to not weigh in every hour on
twitter to just disconnect.
Yeah.
And so profoundly important.
How do you balance between the academic
things that you care about and all the
stuff that we're going to talk about for
the,
for the next hour or so and just being
human because I feel like that's what
people are having trouble dealing with
and I,
I mean that from people that work blue
collar jobs to people that are doing
high level math stuff.
I feel like people are having trouble
separating like just all the noise from
reality.
So I basically have,
professionally speaking,
I have two hats that I wear that have a
professor with all that that entails,
which if I only did that,
it would keep me busy 18 hours a day.
And then there is my public intellectual
hat that I wear,
uh,
over the past few years.
I feel that a large part of my time has
been taken up by the ladder.
And now I'm trying to kind of reign that
in.
So to still remain a viable voice and
the battle of public ideas.
But I need to sort of go back to some of
the fundamentals,
the lab stuff.
Not that I've ever given it a given it
up,
but it takes time as you know,
right.
To build an audience,
to get people excited what you have to
say.
It takes a lot of effort and so I don't
think I have the magical recipe yet,
but I try to every day do a bit of both.
Yeah.
When you made that shift,
which probably was right around when I
met you,
met whatever we did on twitter,
however you connect with someone on
twitter or know whatever that is now,
four years ago or so,
when you made that sort of shift from
academic to someone that was going to
speak their mind publicly and fight with
people publicly and make videos and
interviews and all that stuff.
Did you realize how much of a,
not not just a time suck,
but a,
a,
an important piece of your life?
It was going to become.
I didn't,
uh,
you know,
I'm very much of a purist,
so I'm just excited by things like a
child.
Right?
So I discovered that there's this thing
called social media that allows me to
advertise my ideas with all sorts of
people,
meet people that I would have otherwise
never meet,
like Dave Rubin and countless others,
even random strangers that I get to meet
who sent me beautiful gifts and I get to
know them well,
who selling me stuff that's personal in
their lives.
So I never thought that that would be
possible,
but I'm amazed at the power of the
medium.
And I don't say this in an arrogant
manner,
just walking down the street and
probably you get this probably 10 times
more than I do.
The number of people who recognize you,
who come up to you,
who say they love your work,
who fought,
you know,
we can be on the beach and I'll be
stopped with that.
I can be in a bathroom and someone will
say,
Hey,
Godfather.
And so that's nothing worse than that.
When Your pee against somebody,
the guy next to you,
it's like I'm,
I'm a.
But that,
I,
I look at that with,
with a bit of humility in that,
uh,
it's incredible that we have these
platforms,
which five,
10 years ago,
a guy like me and academia I could have
never hoped to have.
And so it's been wonderful.
It's been a blessing.
Yeah.
Is there a real silver lining to
everything that's going on now,
which is people feel like everyone's
dumber and fighting all the time.
And you know,
I'm a firm believer that most of us,
80 percent of us want the same simple
things into live decent lives and,
and have some food and have some money
and be able to go on vacation and have
some sex and just whatever,
whatever those basics are.
But the silver lining,
while it sounds so crazy,
but obviously if people are recognizing
you and rewarding you for the work you
do,
it shows that there is an intellectual
thirst stays.
It's not being given to you by the
mainstream media,
but it shows that it's out there.
Absolutely.
And I mean,
shows like that are not mainstream.
Uh,
I think eventually this will be the
mainstream.
Uh,
it,
it amazes me how the mainstream media
has sort of doubled down,
you know,
to,
to use a term that we might talk about
later,
had ostrich logic,
but then sand and refuse to sort of
recognize some of the dynamics.
A look,
anything that promotes more discussion
is great.
I only wish that people were sometimes a
bit nicer,
but perhaps they haven't evolved to be
nicer,
but maybe that's,
that should be your next book.
Maybe that's your mission of evil
online.
I mean,
I think we,
we both,
most of the time do this,
right.
We're able to brush it off,
but it takes a,
it takes a toll.
You know,
reading about your,
in my case,
my weight,
my Judaism,
my.
I mean it's just endless.
You know,
a nasty things that are written about
you.
I wish people would recognize that both
of us and many of us will play in this
marketplace of idea,
are really doing it with pure research,
pure reasons to contribute to a
discussion.
And if people could learn to be a bit
nicer,
we would all be richer for it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I wish it,
but I don't sense that coming down the
pike.
All right,
so we're gonna we're gonna do a lot of
stuff here,
but I think just first because it
couches everything else on the free
speech front,
you've become one of the few people that
I know of,
at least on the public side in Canada
that are really fighting the free speech
battle.
Of course,
the real high profile guy also is Jordan
Peterson.
Uh,
and also at the academic level of
course,
um,
what is happening in Canada right now?
I mean,
it,
it seems pretty scary actually when you
hear some of this stuff.
Uh,
Canada I think is desperately trying to
become the number one,
a social justice warrior country in the
world that's trying to catch up to
Germany and Sweden and part because we
have a prime minister who very much a
epitomizes those positions.
And so the endless tsunami of these
types of positions are difficult to keep
up with.
You mentioned earlier that,
uh,
I had appeared in front of the Canadian
Senate to testify.
Maybe I could mention this very briefly.
So there's a bit,
and you're here to tell me what you
think don't even have this.
Bill is a bill that has now since
passed.
Both Jordan Peterson and I are in
separate sessions,
had been asked to appear to discuss some
of our concerns with the bill.
The bill basically refers to
incorporating gender identity and gender
expression within hate crime laws that
if you target someone based on their
gender identity or gender expression,
then it's hateful.
And so then I guess the penalty,
the penalty would be ratcheted up a.
and I appeared in front of the Canadian
Senate to basically argue that the way
that it was worded is so vague and
potentially so dangerous that literally
anything that I teach in my evolutionary
psychology courses could be construed as
quote,
transphobic,
systemic violence.
Uh,
and the reason why I say quotes because
those are terms that a harvard pamphlet,
the LGBTQ office at Harvard had put out
a pamphlet where they argued that people
who support a quilt,
fixed binaries and biological
essentialism fixed binaries is male,
female,
male,
female.
A biological essentialism is arguing
that they are,
you know,
biological realities,
evolved realities,
innate sex differences.
If you promulgate these types of
position,
you are actually engaging in quote Trans
phobic systemic violence.
That's not,
that's not allegorical,
metaphorical.
You literally are being transphobic,
really violent,
and so I argued that anything that I say
in my course when I walk into my course
and introduced the concept of sexual
selection and how sex specific traits
evolve,
and I only use words like male and
female,
I don't refer to the non binary and non
gender and so on.
So any person in the room could say,
hey,
and a 13 week course you never once
recognized my personhood.
You're engaging in Trans phobic systemic
violence.
The answer to this very sober,
a presentation that I gave was that one
of the Canadian senators accused me of
being pro genocide and where did that
come from?
Because apparently the fact that I was
not supporting the bill somehow through
a Gargantuan leap of logic,
you know,
I want it to feather and tar or
transgender people and I,
I specifically argued that all people
deserve to be treated equally under the
law,
but we don't have to uniquely celebrate
your personhood,
right?
There's a distinction between treating
you as an equal member of society and
having to go an extra mile to uniquely
celebrate your personal.
I'll give you another example.
Canada wanted to now create a gender
neutral society.
So the idea being that the marker male
or female,
say on official government documents
should be removed because that small
percentage,
less than one percent,
substantially less than one percent who
consider themselves non-gendered or
nonbinary.
We are going to feel marginalized by
having to write male or female.
So 99 point nine percent of a population
should lose in identifying marker that
is part of their personhood.
I am a male.
I have a child that's mail.
I have a daughter that's female.
I'm married to a woman that's female.
All of these things should be removed
because someone might be marginalized by
that biological reality.
It's insanity.
So for someone like you that,
that builds in academia,
but more importantly that deal in the
realm of science and you have to base
things on fact,
this is actually a direct assault on you
in a certain way.
Right?
Like you're in,
you're talking about something that's
important societal issue,
but really it's rational self interest.
You want to be able to do your job that
you have been trained to do at the
highest level without having outside
fear.
So when you finished up that talk over
there,
did you feel better or worse?
For the course of it?
I felt better and that at least my
positions were on record.
I didn't have any a sense that the bill
would be defeated.
I felt very strongly that it would
ultimately pass just because of the
reality of the dynamics of the political
system there.
But at least I knew that Jordan had been
heard.
I hadn't been heard.
It's officially on record.
Uh,
so in that sense I felt I had done my
quote,
civic duty,
but I have no illusions that I,
that I would help sway the vote.
I knew that we will ultimately lose the
battle.
So when people say,
I'll see online,
sometimes people say,
Oh,
you guys are overestimating when someone
says racist or bigoted or homophobia,
Islamophobia,
any of this stuff.
This really goes to show why these are
not.
We're not just making up this fight,
this fight,
forget what people are saying online.
This fight is now starting to codify
things into.
That's absolutely right.
I mean,
but nevermind law.
I mean people say,
well,
you know,
don't take these extreme examples.
Well,
you have Bret Weinstein on this show.
I mean,
is he not a real person who's
experienced real death threats?
So people always think that we're in in
a sense engaging in an exaggerated,
exaggerated narrative by pointing to
these extreme cases.
But what is extreme today,
tomorrow becomes mundane.
And so this is why canaries in the coal
mine stand up and sing and warn people.
Uh,
but unfortunately,
apparently people don't want to listen.
Do you ever think that it's Kinda,
it's Kinda sucky to be someone that sees
something a little bit early?
I think it's sometimes like,
it's great at a certain level,
right?
Because that's what makes people care
about what you're saying because they
have a,
they have a twinge of,
oh,
that guy's onto something.
But like when I sat here with Brett and
he at the time,
I don't know what he identifies as now,
but the time he was saying I'm a,
you know,
uh,
he said,
deeply I think deeply committed,
progressive,
uh,
I now know that he,
at least I don't want to speak for them,
but basically it said,
you know,
the progressive train has left him or he
grew up or perhaps I don't know that he
would say it so specifically.
But,
but I knew it as I was sitting here with
him and he was saying how he was this,
this deep progressive.
I knew that it was just a matter of a
month or two months or whatever before
he'd see the same thing that we've all
been talking about for that long.
So there's like a joy and also like a
depression in that I think,
well,
my wife often tells me that I'm an avant
garde both and my scientific career and
in my public engagements,
I think it's in part because I do see
these trends early,
but also because I have the courage to
speak about them.
You and I both see them at the same
time,
but if I only have the courage to say it
than I appear as though I'm the avant
garde guy.
Whereas you saw the same pattern but
were too afraid to say it.
And so in a sense it's a unique
combination of both seeing these
patterns early enough,
but then having the courage to voice my
opinion.
And of course that ultimately and
academia is not something contrary to
what you might think is not something
that's desired.
Herd mentality is really,
as we say in French dirty girl.
It's the.
It's the official way to be.
Don't cause too much waves.
We don't want trouble here.
Right?
Which is so the reverse of what true
pursuit of knowledge is.
So when people say that,
I'll also hear that,
well,
you're,
you guys are a overblowing what's
happening on college campuses or your
overblowing that there isn't enough
diversity of thought there as someone
that's on college campuses,
as someone that has testified about
what's happening there and as someone
that knows plenty of academics in,
in Canada and the United States,
are we overblowing this?
Absolutely not.
I mean,
when it comes to issues like political
matters,
uh,
how people make pronouncements about a
given religion or they or not,
there is APP.
Everybody walks to the exact same beat.
Uh,
again,
I could just use,
for example,
anecdotal evidence or,
or I could cite actual studies,
but let's go with anecdotal evidence.
And I think I might've mentioned this
before on the show.
If you just go to my personal facebook
page,
you never see anyone and I've got
hundreds of academic friends on my
personal facebook page.
Not a single person has ever uttered
deposition regarding,
say trump,
that I would construe as surprising,
surprising in the sense that they might
say something that is positive of him or
favorable,
or why someone might have voted for him.
Every single academic friend that I have
apes the identical same position.
And that's simply not possible,
right?
Within any group of people,
you would expect some diversity of
thinking.
Well,
apparently there isn't.
All right,
so let's talk about trump a little bit.
Now.
I want to be clear that right now,
as we tape this,
I'm about to go off the grid for a
month.
So this is going up about 12 or 13 days
after we're taping this.
So in the way that we live these days,
trump could have done anything by then,
the impeachment proceedings could have
been regarding the monarchy,
could've started.
Who the hell knows what's going to
happen?
But as we tape this on,
what's today?
July 28th,
uh,
2017.
Um,
I think you've been basically pretty
fair on trump.
I don't sense that you love the guy.
No,
but I don't sense that you're have a
deranged hatred of the guy.
Is that a fair estimation?
Again?
That's exactly right.
And usually when I've come out in
support of trump,
that's not usually what I've done.
Instead,
I have offered very a reasonable
psychological reasons why someone might
vote for trump.
And so,
uh,
I,
you may remember this in one of my
conversations,
I think it was with Sam Harris or I
explained the actual decision rule that
someone might use in arriving at a
decision to vote for trump.
And I'll just repeat it for here.
So when you're,
when you're choosing between two multi
attribute products,
two cars to people to hire two mates to
marry their,
each defined by many attributes.
So there are many decision rules that I
could use in deciding whether to choose
alternative ar alternative be one of
these decision rules.
It's called the lexical graphic rule,
which basically says,
take your most important attribute to
you and choose the alternative that
scores higher on that most important
attribute.
That's the only thing you look at.
So in the case of applying that rule to
trump,
if let's say,
my most important attribute,
my lexical graphic rule attribute is
immigration,
and rightly or wrongly,
I viewed that trump scores better on
immigration.
And if I use that rule,
I will choose trump.
Even though if I had looked at all of
the attributes of defining trump and
Clinton,
I might've ended up choosing Clinton.
So as someone who studies psychology of
decision making,
there are very,
very clear cognitive processes that we
could use to explain why a very
reasonable person might end up choosing
trump.
Now,
that doesn't mean that I,
as I jokingly say on twitter,
that I have posters of trump and my
bedroom.
It simply means that as someone who is
this passionate who's studying it from
my Canadian context,
as a behavioral decision theorists,
I could understand why people would vote
for trump.
Just uttering that the amount of hate
that you get and the amount of,
you know,
ostracizing that happens within academia
because you dare say something that
seems to support trump.
It means craziness.
How much of that do you think is sort of
the elite Ism of academia?
In other words,
your saying something that's that you're
using your the discipline that you have
to give this idea of why people may have
voted for trump,
so you're separating sort of the the Gad
human part you're saying this is.
This is what I think is happening based
on information that I have versus other
academics that because they want to go
to all the parties with the academics
and all of that stuff,
that trump is sort of the reverse
academic,
so the idea that they could say anything
nice about the person who's the reverse,
who speaks in such ridiculous speech
patterns and says so many over the top
things and tweets like a madman,
that somehow that would all be thrust
upon them.
Right.
The way that I would frame exactly what
you said as the elitist,
the academics,
the ivory tower folks,
excuse me.
They viewed trump as a fatal attack on
their sense of aesthetics.
It's he is an injury to their aesthetic.
The way he speaks,
the way he annunciates,
the way he shakes hands.
Everything about him as an affront to
their hardiness and therefore there's
this visceral hate of him at an
aesthetic level.
He's grotesque,
he's an older,
he's a buffoon and I see this,
this position and unstated amongst some
of our common friends where I typically
would consider those to be those climate
friends to be very sophisticated.
This passion of thinkers,
but they've succumbed to that trap where
they are simply unable to stomach the
possibility that this person could be
sitting in the highest office.
I think it really is that simple.
They despise his sense of aesthetics.
So I sent that.
Your position on him is sort of where
mine is in that forgetting what I think
about him personally and again,
I can say the phrase moral center.
Every time I bring them up again,
don't know what his moral center is.
I'm still confused as whether he's
waking up everyday and making all the
decisions as they come on the flight or
if there's a grand plan or any of that.
But the part that I like is the part
that the media has taken it on the Chin
and basically been blown apart and that
I think is what we needed in this
country.
Um,
I sent.
You're kind of with me on.
Absolutely.
Look to use a cliche that I don't
particularly like from sort of the
buzzwords of business.
He is a disruptor,
right?
To the extent that you wanted someone.
It's funny because they all loved
disrupters,
but now they,
every now and again you're going to get
a disruptor you don't like,
right?
I mean,
he's the structure in every possible way
that you could conceive of that term.
Right?
He's from outside the political class.
He's never held political office.
He speaks differently from them.
He's a brawler.
He's a real estate guy.
His,
his,
his language pattern is that of a thug
in grade eight.
He is somewhat buffoonish,
so in every possible way that we could
think of what they aspire to.
Barack Obama,
he's the Anti Barack Obama.
Barack Obama is sophisticated.
These majestic.
He's a great orator.
Right?
But again,
those are superficial cues,
right?
Typically when we,
when,
when we look at the psychology of
persuasion,
we look at substantive cues or cosmetic
use,
right?
How tall you are is something that
people use when they judge your
leadership qualities,
but if objectively it shouldn't matter,
right?
And so in a similar manner,
the fact that he might speak in a way
that is clearly much more buffoonish
than say Barack Obama doesn't
necessarily speak to whether you
appreciate his policies or not.
Yeah.
And that's the part that I think is
interesting because again,
as I said,
we're,
we're taping this about two weeks before
it's going to air.
So who the hell knows what's going to
happen?
But even just in the last couple of
days,
there was this thing with,
uh,
with scar moochy and,
or the recording and you know,
bannon wants to suck his own cock and
blah,
blah.
All this stuff.
And everyone's freaking out.
I'm looking at twitter and all the
journalists,
all the lefties,
everyone's freaking out over the
language and how can they talk like
this?
And all I was thinking was,
yeah,
I mean I guess in some perfect world
that we don't exist.
I wish that government officials would
be a little more professional,
but the idea that Obama people and Bush
before that and Clinton before that,
and then you can go back forever
literally go back to George Washington,
the idea that they didn't speak it with
blue language and say nasty things about
each other and all of that stuff.
And the infighting and back to the idea
that this has just appeared now is just
outrageous.
It's just fake.
It's full outrage.
Again,
it's trying to maintain the facade of
the ivory tower,
right?
This highfalutin way of Bologna.
I mean it wasn't a Nixon who,
when you look at his,
his transcripts,
every second word that a,
yeah,
these guys are not a Oxford professors
of philosophy.
And by the way,
I wouldn't want them to be.
I want them to be human.
That that's also the irony.
It's like when Bill Clinton said I don't
inhale,
it was like you could admit you inhale
or when Barack Obama gets did say he
inhaled,
but it was like the idea that we have to
feel guilty about all of these things.
Like we're all humans,
we curse some of us drink or smoke pot
or do some other shit.
And just to mention a couple of other
qualities that I think trump does have
a.
You know,
when you face a lot of conflicts there,
there's some research,
I don't remember who it's by.
I think it's made by Gregory at Texas
Tech,
if I'm not mistaken.
He looked at what types of leaders do
people wish to elect as a function of
the environment.
Is there for example,
war or not,
and so our preference for a particular
type of leadership style changes as a
function of the environment as you would
expect.
Well,
to the extent that we now face a lot of
chaos with terrorism,
with the immigration problems and so on.
I would have predicted that someone like
trump,
a guy who appears to be a bit reckless
of periods to be as though,
am I going to press the Red Button?
Am I not going to press it even though
he's not going,
but the fact that he,
he exudes those types of signals,
I think to a lot of people that is
equality because you have very dangerous
guys in the neighborhood who might feel
intimidated by someone who appears to be
a risk taker who appears to be a
brawler,
and so in that sense,
here's another psychological reason why
a lot of people might have latched onto
him,
so it also goes to show why when Obama
or Hillary wouldn't say radical Islamic
terror or whatever phrase that you
wanted to say,
a and trump would just say anything,
and she said trump was just given them
the red meat.
They were going,
give me something.
Give me something that makes sense.
Then trump says something.
It's probably over the top,
but they're going,
well,
at least it's something exactly right.
I should mention.
I know that we both tentatively agreed
that talked much about Islam before the
show,
but let me just mention one or two
things.
I think it is a misnomer to constantly
come up with qualifiers before the word
Islam and let me explain why that is.
There is not Islam,
there is not Islamism Islam,
Islam as part of Islam.
Islam as a set of codifying ideas that
has a spiritual element and it has a
political element.
That political element is Islam.
Islam,
the manner in which now people are
talking about Islam.
Islam is.
It's,
it's,
it's something that is outside of Islam
and I understand the reason why people
want to do this.
It's because they feel as though it's
two Gauche to frontally attacker
religion,
so if you attack something that has
magically ism at the end of it,
Islam,
that's okay.
If you attack Islam,
that's not okay,
but the reality is if we're truly going
to have a serious and honest
conversation about this topic,
we have to recognize that it's not
radical Islam.
It's not Islam Islam.
It's not militant violent extremism and
and every other permutation of a
euphemism that you come up with.
It's Islam.
Now.
Most people choose to practice a
cafeteria version of Islam.
They pick the parts that they like and
they ignore the endless parts that they
don't like and that becomes their
personal relationship with Islam.
That doesn't end that,
but most people do that with most
religions.
Most people do that with most
relationships.
You and I and everybody else don't stay
up worrying about seventh day adventist,
so,
so the extent that Islam is now on the
radar and we have to talk about it
honestly,
we have to stop trying to give a free
pass to Islam,
but the real problem is something else.
Some variant of it.
Islam is codified in the Koran.
It's called the fight in the Heidi's
score of filing the Sierra,
the biography of Muhammad.
That's it.
Now,
is there a way that I could read those
techs and come up with a message of
brotherly love and love for Jews?
No,
that's not Islam.
Islam,
radical Islam that Islam.
Now,
as I say this,
I also recognize that 95 percent of all
Muslims are just as nice as anybody that
you could hope to have.
That's not because they practice a
gentle version of Islam,
codified in some other set of tax.
That's because they're decent human
beings will decide to like the rest of
us pick and choose which parts apply to
their daily lives and not.
So we have to be very careful and honest
about.
And I hope that at some point soon a
greater number of our common friends
will actually hear what I'm saying now,
by the way,
for the record,
because you just mentioned that we said
we were going to talk about that much
about Islam.
It's not because we're afraid.
I think we both,
we both talked about it down,
but we realized that we wanted to get
more into some science stuff and plenty
of other stuff.
So I just want,
I just want to be clear because
otherwise people are combined and they
just see they're,
they're afraid now.
Um,
all right.
So very quickly on that though.
So you are writing a new book right now,
which,
which deals with this and deals with
ostrich parasitic syndrome.
Yes.
So very quickly for those that don't
know what o p,
s is,
let's talk about that and then I won't
talk about the book and then we'll move.
Sure,
sure.
Thanks.
Thanks for asking.
So let me sort of step back and give
some some analogies.
So if you look in the animal kingdom,
there are many cases where you have
brain worms or pathogens that enter the
brain of a particular species and it
renders that species zombified.
Okay?
So example,
a,
a mouse can be infected by a particular
pathogen.
It loses its innate fear of cats.
That's not a good thing if you're a mom,
there's another type of brain warm that
attacks the brains of ungulates,
let's say moose or elk or deer,
and they become,
they become completely zombified where
they just circle and the same in the
same spot until these looming predators
come and eat them.
Right?
Think of another example of someone who
suffers from Anorexia nervosa.
Right there they're thinking now has
become so disordered that even though
they only weigh 70 pounds,
they look at themselves in the mirror
and they genuinely think that there are.
They remain grotesquely obese and they
need to lose a bit more weight.
Right?
So there are all sorts of ways.
There are all sorts of analogies where
whether it be in the human context or
with other species where our brain
become hijacked by either disordered
thinking or literally a pathogen.
So I took these ideas and I argued,
well what could explain the collective
psychosis,
the collective departure from reason
that we see being exhibited in the west,
not only as related to Islam but as
relating,
for example,
to the negation of the idea that humans
are biological beings,
that there are sex differences that they
are.
So this ostrich person x syndrome is not
only applicable to Islam,
and so that's how I came up with that
term to to,
to use the metaphor of the Australia
buries his head even though it doesn't
really do that,
but it's an apt metaphor of the denial
of reliance,
reality,
parasitic in that a genuinely
progressive sizes,
your brain and you lose your ability to
think.
Now I specifically apply it to Islam
because typically the ostriches that
succumb to ops got engage in all sorts
of cognitive distortions to protect
Islam,
which ironically you're talking about
people that are not Muslim for the most
part,
right?
Absolutely.
So,
so,
so many of the ops suffers will end up
being non Muslims who because they've
been pressurized by ops,
will come up with all sorts of
disordered thinking to defend Islam.
Right?
And I give many,
many such examples.
Now I take this idea and it's part of my
book.
So the book is tentatively titled Death
Of the West by a thousand cuts.
This is the idea that we,
we are currently facing this opioid
epidemic because of a perfect confluence
of full intellectual movements that have
porosities our brains,
so it's not one thing.
It's radical feminism,
it's identity politics,
it's cultural and moral relativism.
It's postmodernism,
each of which uses its own machinery to
personalize our brain to move away from
reason,
right?
I reject the idea that there's male and
female.
Well,
evolutionary biologists and evolutionary
psychologists don't.
Right?
I reject that they are an eight sex
differences.
While the average three year old knows
that there is such a thing,
I reject that there's any link between
Islam and any terrorism.
Islam is peace,
right?
So how did we lead to this?
What we we lead with?
We were led to this by 40,
50 years of these movements chipping
away at our commitment to reason and
hence death of the West by a thousand
cuts.
So what was the failure of the side of
reason then for the last 40 or 50 years?
What did the people that were reasonable
that were sensible and trying to deal
with things honestly and see the world
as it is,
not how they wanted it to be,
where,
where did they fail?
Well,
I,
so if I say,
if I speak in the academic ecosystem,
I think the fact that we tolerated
these,
these affront to human decency and human
reason like postmodernism to exist,
it really came from a place of,
you know,
we have to tolerate,
in this case the intolerable,
intolerable,
and that nothing could be further from
being anti scientific than
postmodernism.
Postmodernism say there are no objective
truths other than of course the one
truth that there are the,
you really got to be exactly so
postmodernism and all of its endless
footprints,
profundity and,
and,
and you know,
full nonsense is really a direct attack
on science.
Right?
Science presumes that there are certain
universal regularities that we're going
to use the scientific method to try to
better understand.
Well,
imagine if now a bunch of nihilists come
along who say there is no such thing as
true.
There is no such thing as objective
truth.
Well,
that chips away at the reason why we all
exist in science to try to understand
the world,
but how would academia academia fight
that properly?
If the idea is we have to battle,
you know,
I know we both believe in the battle of
ideas.
So if the,
uh,
if the idea here is that in colleges
you're supposed to have these battles.
I know you beat it with better ideas,
but how,
how would that have actually happened?
Well,
I think what probably ended up
happening,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm surmising here,
I'm not sure how it happened,
but I'm guessing that most people are in
their daily lives,
right?
That for the same reasons why most
people don't speak out against Islam.
But you know,
let Dave Rubin worry about that,
that let someone else were thrilled.
You know,
I'm busy preparing for my daughter's
graduation.
I got to pick up the tomatoes for my
groceries today.
Right?
And so people diffused responsibility to
others.
So in a sense,
there is a split within academia from
the sciences,
the natural and social sciences.
By the way,
it is wrong to presume that the social
sciences are any less committed to the
scientific method in the natural
sciences,
which is up to that.
We could do that.
I do want to get to that.
After that,
people are busy,
right?
So the chemists sits in his lab and he
sees that there's a bunch of humanities
guys authoring utter,
you know,
Jibberish,
right?
Well he's.
He doesn't necessarily have the time and
energy and proclivity to weigh in on it
and so somehow these guys found a little
niche within the ecosystem called
academia and they flourished and they
multiplied and the cancer spread and
metastasize and now 40,
50 years later,
you have generations of students who
have spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars being trained to be naturally
lobotomized morons.
Yeah.
So the metaphor is perfect of this
parasite that gets in there and keeps
multiplying.
And I can picture now the biology
professor going,
alright,
I kind of see that,
but it's not going to affect me here
except now what we're seeing is it's
starting to even creep into that.
Have you seen this?
The business,
great picture online of a,
you know,
somebody selling the shirt and it says
there are no genders or you can only buy
it in male or female.
And it's like,
there you go.
Alright,
so let's talk about the natural sciences
versus the social sciences first for the
layman,
what is the difference?
They both have science in the Gad come
on,
right?
So the lay,
the lay person will often use these sort
of simplifying your risks sticks to
determine what is science versus not if
you're wearing a lab coat,
if you have,
if you have a couple of chemical
formulas that science because to the
average lay person that's impenetrable.
Uh,
on the other hand,
most people have,
for example,
of folk psychology,
they have an innate sense of what
psychology is and therefore to the
extent that they feel that they can
contribute,
even though they might be laypeople,
somehow that's less impenetrable to
them.
So they then will create this false
dichotomy where chemistry and physics,
that's real science,
but sociology,
you know,
it's for people who couldn't hack it in,
in,
in physics.
The reality is that the only difference
is what are the phenomena that you're
studying across these two general
rubrics of science and the social
sciences.
You're studying psychology,
anthropology,
economics,
sociology.
It could be as rigorous as the natural
sciences.
So let me give you an example.
If you could,
if you're a sociologist,
you could study sociometric,
which is you know,
for example,
how this power diffused within a network
and you could use very fancy mathematics
graph theory to try to understand this.
So the type of mathematical modeling
that you would use to study how power
diffusers with a network is actually a
very fancy mathematical approach,
but sociology has somehow been co opted
by the activists,
right?
So we then view it as being less
scientific,
but science is simply means adhering
truthfully to the scientific method.
I posit a hypothesis.
I think about the data that I would need
to collect that would either falsify or
not the hypothesis.
I collect that data.
I apply some sort of statistical
analysis and mathematical analysis to
analyze the data and then I go one way
or the other.
That could be just as applied.
If it's an economics or if it is in
physics,
so it is wrong because I often get
letters and emails from people asking
me,
well as psychology really escience,
and then of course it's the science.
Ultimately what is more laudable than
studying the most important organism
that we know called humans.
Right?
So,
so it's not as though by the sheer
nature of what physicists study,
they are real scientists,
but the sociologist is not.
And by the way,
I'm not trying to defend sociologist
here because I often am the one who's
criticizing.
Usually I'm criticizing them for
deviating from the scientific method.
What makes them less scientists is that
they become activists and not
scientists,
but you could be just as much as a
scientist if you study something in
business or if you study something in
chemistry.
Yeah.
It's interesting that you say talk about
activists,
not scientists,
because that's what I've been saying
about journalists.
These people are not doing true
journalism,
in fact,
finding anymore and reporting nice and
based on evidence.
What they're doing is letting their own
biases slam right into the middle of
that thing.
And so for,
so one of the things that,
uh,
I will say differentiates the science,
the natural sciences from the social
sciences,
and that's very much at the heart of the
work that I do.
The natural sciences have organized
trees of knowledge.
So in physics,
people agree on a set of core knowledge
that at this point has become
unassailable,
not withstanding the fact that they
still have the epistemic humility to
say,
Oh,
if new provision,
it's only provisional,
if something now falsifies it,
I'm willing to revise it,
but the bedrock,
the bedrock is there.
There's core knowledge that is now
unassailable.
And physics and chemistry.
There aren't chemists who are for the
periodic table against it,
right?
Therefore,
you could build coherent trees of
knowledge or the term that I love to
use,
which was reintroduced into the common
lexicon by Eo Wilson,
the evolutionary biologist at Harvard.
It's consilience unity of knowledge.
So the natural sciences by the,
by the nature of how they test theories
have these organized trees of knowledge.
That's what's lacking in the social
sciences.
And the reason it's lacking,
it's not because of the social sciences
are any less scientific,
it's because it is easier for ideologies
to creep into the social sciences.
Right?
So if I'm a libertarian or a Marxist,
I might study economics in a way that is
very polluted by my personal ideology.
So it's not that the social sciences are
epistemologically and he inherently less
scientific than chemistry.
It's that biases are easier to creep in.
It's funny because I'll hear and I
talked to.
Sometimes someone's a leftist economist
or libertarian economists or whatever it
is.
I'd always think it's kind of funny,
like we all have our own beliefs
economically.
I'm a little more libertarian these
days,
but if you're studying something within
the window of the way you want it to be,
it's by default is going to be a little
screwy.
Absolutely.
And as I said,
it is naturally more difficult for your
personal ideological biases to come into
a something that you're studying in
organic chemistry.
Although I should mention that there
have been famous cases where even hard
sciences have been deeply polluted by
ideology.
So Lysenko Ism Lysenko was a Russian
Soviet Union,
uh,
geneticists who proposed a theory of
genetics that he thought was more inline
with Marxist philosophy that was a wrong
theory of genetics that led to a massive
famine and to the death of millions of
people.
So even it's not as though hard
scientists are a inoculated from the
possibility of being progressive advised
by some of these ideological biases.
Do you think it's too late for the hard
sciences to be protected?
Like is it too late for them to turn
their forcefield on?
Because we do see this creeping now in
biology.
I mean Bret Weinstein's been talking
about this now that now it's really
reaching its hand into that which could
have horrific repercussions for.
Well listen,
when,
when a,
when a scientist and the 21st century
I'm speaking of myself right now,
it has to appear in front of the
Canadian Senate to argue that there is
such a thing as male and female.
That evolutionary biology is based on
the recognition that there is sexual
dimorphism in human sexual dimorphism is
a fancy term for saying basically that
they are evolved sex differences.
Humans,
men,
bales are bigger than females,
right?
That's a sexual dimorphism.
So the fact that I have to appear in
front of the Canadian Senate to actually
argue these things demonstrates how far
the snake has gone into the den.
Yeah.
So in a weird way,
your position as a evolutionary
biologist is a,
is sort of right at the front of the
type of person that this ideology would
attack,
right?
Just to grab.
I'm an evolutionary psychologists.
Psychologists are not biologists,
biologists,
I,
although I apply evolutionary biological
principles.
Sorry.
Uh,
yeah.
It's,
I mean,
it's,
it's craziness,
right?
And,
and,
and the reason why I'm so if you like,
aware of the epistemological dichotomy
between the natural and social sciences
is because my scientific career of 20
plus years has really been straddling
both these fields,
right?
I apply evolutionary biology to study
consumer behavior.
Consumer behavior would be construed as
something within the social sciences.
Evolutionary biology is something that
is within the natural sciences,
so I really am very much steeped in both
cultures and I see the extent to which
it is easier for people to succumb to
their personal biases and the social
sciences.
Let me just give you one example.
If you start off with the premise that
you can't agree on whether there is such
a thing as an eight sex differences or
not,
how could you from that starting point,
ever build a tree of knowledge that's
organized?
If at this most fundamental level,
we can agree that there is such a thing
as male or female,
then we're done.
We're cooked.
A physicists don't suffer from that
problem and that's why they make much
better progress than than social
scientists do.
So as someone that studies marketing and
why we behave,
how we do what turns us on,
what turns us off,
all of that.
In a weird way,
you were.
You were prepared for everything that
was going to happen politically right
now and what's happening on the academic
front because all of these things,
they're all marketing in a way.
Trump,
it's marketing.
Hillary.
Market yourself in a,
in a certain way.
So the trends were all their life that
has marketing.
Yeah.
So when people asked me,
so what,
what do you study as,
as a professor of marketing,
and I always answered them.
Everything you do in life is marketing.
You market yourself on the mating
market.
We even use the euphemisms of the
marketplace,
right?
You know,
you position yourself in the
marketplace,
you market yourself and the labor
market.
You market yourself to friends,
you position yourself depending on
whether you wish to belong to a group or
not.
Animals communicate with each other,
right?
When,
when animals advertise,
for example,
when the peacock,
the peacock is literally engaging and
conspicuous advertising.
So everything in life as marketing.
So one of the reasons why I was very
much interested in applying all of my
training in marketing is because that's
I think where all the sexy stuff is,
right?
We take all of these principles from
psychology,
from economics,
from biology,
uh,
and then I apply them in areas that are
of greatest import to most people.
Is there something kind of scary about
that though?
That it's not that the best ideas will
necessarily when it's that the best
marketed ideas or win and those often
are not the same thing.
Very good point.
Listen,
I'm,
I'm right now working on my next book
and I just connected with a,
a what appears to be a wonderful that's
very agent and he actually made this
exact point.
He said,
look,
what's really important as we move
forward with your book is how to market
it because there'll be people who will
be very resistant to the ideas that you
propose in that book.
So again,
everything is marketing.
So basically if you want to.
So did trump,
do you think have not to bring
everything back then,
but he must've had,
I guess as a businessman and putting his
name all over these things for the last
30 years.
He had an innate understanding of
exactly what you're talking about and
absolutely.
Well listen,
I could speak to one thing that he knew
very well.
He could completely read that many
people,
the silent majority or certainly a
sizable minority.
If we're going to use the popular vote
that we're fed up with political
correctness and said,
I'm going to be the anti pc guy,
and he bet pretty much everything on
that and it turns out that people
responded to it,
right?
He could have equivocated,
he could have been more careful with his
words,
but he sort of,
he flies off the handle because he
realized that the general atmosphere was
most people,
whether they're having chats on facebook
or at their workplace by the water
cooler at the university,
are tired of feeling stifled,
are tired of feeling scared of the next
syllable that they might miss other that
might ruin their careers.
And he said,
I am the anti pc warrior,
and people responded to that marketing
position.
So as someone that studies all this
stuff,
what do you think people really drives
people at the end of the day?
You know,
I mentioned before,
as I say,
often I think it's just a couple things.
You want to have a job,
you want to have some money,
hopefully a house,
maybe a family,
maybe some sex,
whatever.
Just the basic stuff that we all do.
You think those are really just the
undesired?
So in,
in several of my books,
I actually answered that question in the
following way.
I map consumption acts onto four key
Darwinian modules.
So think about how maslow's hierarchy,
if you know,
so at the basic level there's the
physiological needs and then belonging,
safety needs belonging.
This needs all the way up to self
actualization.
Well,
his theory was really based on his
humanistic philosophy.
In other words,
he had this bias,
this,
this ideological bias of how humans
should be.
It wasn't necessarily grounded in an
understanding of biology.
So I took this principal and I said,
no,
let's see what actually drives people
based on biological principles.
And so my four Darwinian modules are the
survival module.
So a lot of the things that we do are
related to our survival instincts.
So our preference for fatty foods,
right?
Why is it that it's easy for us to
succumb to the desert effect having an
extra piece of dessert when we've
already had more calories and we need
to.
Well,
that comes from the fact that our
gustatory preferences have evolved in an
environment of caloric scarcity and
caloric uncertainty.
So your taste buds and mine are vestiges
of an environment long gone,
but that we've evolved to have.
But can your brain evolved to override
that?
That's actually called the mismatch
hypothesis.
I'll come to it and sec.
Okay,
so.
So first we've got survival,
then we've got a reproduction,
everything related to sex.
Why do men,
why are 99 percent of Ferrari owners
mail?
Because that's the form of peacocking.
So the peacock stale is literally the
Aston Martin that men drive,
right?
And of course both men and women engage
in sexual signaling.
So first we've got survival instincts.
We've got a reproduction,
then we've got kin selection.
Kin Selection is the mechanism that
explains why is it that I would jump
into the river to save three of my
brothers.
If all I care about is my survivability,
why would I ever take the risk on them?
Well,
when you realize that a natural
selection operates at the level of the
gene,
then saving three brothers,
each of whom share half the genes with
me makes sense.
Now you might say,
well,
how do you apply that in consumer
behavior while gift giving practices?
Right?
So how I modulate the size of the gift
that I give to different people turns
out to be perfectly correlated to the
genetic relatedness with each of these
people.
I give larger gifts to my brother than I
do to my second cousin.
I may not do this consciously.
I may not know all these fancy theories
what I'm doing,
but our brains have evolved to recognize
that people are not of equal genetic
relatedness.
And the fourth module is reciprocal
altruism.
Okay?
I jumped into the river to save three
brothers,
but why would I jump in to save Dave
Ruben?
He's not my brother.
Well,
that comes from this evolved idea of tit
for tat.
I scratch your back.
You scratch mine.
Well,
today I might jump to save you with the
expectation that tomorrow when I'm
drowning,
hopefully you'll come and save me.
So this idea of reciprocity has evolved
for social species,
and again,
it explains why I will invite you out
for dinner when it's your birthday and
you will hopefully reciprocate when it's
mine.
From a strict economic perspective,
there's no point to this,
right?
Let's not invite each other.
We'll be at the same final position.
The reason why we do this exchange is to
oil our friendship and our bond.
So I argue that much of consumer
behavior could be mapped onto these four
modules.
So now to your other question,
no,
it is very difficult for our brain to
catch up to a current reality.
So for example,
men have evolved sex,
sexual territoriality as a,
as a,
as a strong element of their psychology,
right?
They don't like women to be promiscuous
if there with them they get,
they get sexually jealous.
If another man touches a woman and so
on.
Well why would that have evolved?
That goes both ways,
right?
Men and women,
interestingly.
Okay,
so that's interesting.
This is not my voice.
This is David buses work,
a colleague,
evolution psychologist at the University
of Texas,
Austin.
He looked at what some of his colleagues
at romantic infidelity versus sexual
infidelity.
So he brought in people to the lab.
He,
he set him up with all sorts of
physiological measures to measure their
stress and had them read one of two
vignettes.
Uh,
your,
your husband right now is,
uh,
having sex with the gorgeous secretary
versus a,
your husband is developing an emotional
bond with his coworker.
She laughs at his jokes.
They,
they get along.
So in one case you trigger sexual
fidelity and the other one romantic
infidelity.
Well,
it turns out that women respond much
more,
uh,
adversely to romantic infidelity than to
sexual infidelity.
And that effect is reversed for men.
Now that doesn't mean that women
appreciate sexual infidelity or are
tolerant of it,
but it's less.
So now,
what are the reasons for it?
Well,
it turns out that sexual infidelity is a
profoundly important evolutionary
problem for men because we're a parental
species where males invest a lot of
their children.
It doesn't make a lot of sense for me to
invest for many,
many years until little johnny grows up
to be sexually mature.
So then find out that it was the sexy
Greek or Roman gardener who sired that
guy,
right?
Therefore,
I evolve this,
the psychological apparatus to try to
protect against this possibility.
So I am very intolerant of sexual
infidelity.
If a woman cheats on a man that almost
guarantees the end of the solution the
other way around.
It doesn't.
On the other hand,
what's the greatest threat to a woman's
interest?
It's not that he has a sexual dalliance
one time.
This is why men very naively often will
say,
I just had sex with her once.
She meant nothing to me.
They actually think that this is helping
because there is no emotional bond
between us.
It's a one time thing,
right?
On the other hand,
if a man develops a emotional tie with a
woman,
that's a much greater predictor of him
leaving the relationship and that's why
women respond so adversity to emotional
infidelity.
But if a man says,
well,
it was just a one time thing,
isn't he?
Then let's assume it's the truth for a
second guy who does it one time.
He's telling the woman what she wants to
hear right?
I mean,
what,
what if it's true for him,
it's also what she does want to hear it
because she doesn't want to hear.
Well,
it's certainly a much better for him to
say it was a onetime thing rather than I
think I'm falling for her and we're
planning on having sex and another 37
times,
but he genuinely honestly is trying to
convey to her that she literally meant
nothing to him.
He's perfectly able to decouple the
sexual act from any emotional
investment.
Right.
When you think about when John's we'll
go see prostitutes,
what do they typically tell you?
It's perfectly unencumbered sex and I'm
able to have sex with her and walk away.
I pay for that walking away.
Right.
So again,
that speaks to evolved sex differences.
This whole conversation that we've had
might be trans phobic,
systemic violence on their bill.
C,
60,
because look,
I didn't talk about the non or nonbinary
yeah,
I must be a genocide supporter
naturally,
but I'm glad you just mentioned that
because as you're saying is,
I'm not even exactly sure what my
question is,
but is there an element a,
as you're sitting across from a gay
person that enters some of the
questions?
Uh,
I don't think we finished the mismatch
question.
Oh,
okay.
Wait,
let's get to that.
Let me finish that then we'll talk about
homosexuality given me a lot here.
So that's why I want it to do the
science.
That's why we're here.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
So it.
Our brains don't catch up as quickly as
we otherwise would want.
So for example,
the fact that look,
the top killers,
the top medical killers,
colon cancer,
heart disease,
diabetes,
from an evolutionary medicine
perspective,
the argument is that it stems from the
fact that today we live in an
environment of plenty,
but our gustatory preferences have
evolved in an environment of caloric
scar city and uncertainty.
That mismatch between our current
environment of plenty and the
environment in which we evolved causes
some of these top killers.
So to answer your question in a long
winded way,
know our brains don't catch up if there
were selection pressures for the next x
number of years to cause an evolutionary
trajectory to change that it would
happen,
but typically for even the most basic
genetic selection,
it might take say 5,000
years.
Right?
So I guess what I'm talking about then
is for the person that never goes for
the desert or never engines on this or
that,
that's not an evolutionary thing.
As much as it's someone that's aware of
someone that's educated and aware of
that these things can cause health
problems and you might be like,
I live here in la where everyone doesn't
eat this or that or doesn't want gluten.
Everyone's.
Everyone has celiac disease,
which no one had celiac disease.
So that's not evolution.
That's just sort of doing something
different with the information you have.
Right?
It's not on the macro level and
evolutionary thing and sometimes you
have multiple Darwinian pools pulling
you in different directions.
So that the net effect is zero.
So for example,
when I explained why they are
evolutionary pressures for both men and
women to cheat on their longterm
partners,
that doesn't mean that it's a fatalistic
argument,
it's not biological determinism,
we're doomed to cheat because we also
have evolved the moral calculus,
right?
Our morality.
Unless you're a religious person that
thinks that it comes from God,
our morality has also evolved through
the exact same evolutionary forces that
explain why we have opposable thumbs.
And so on the one hand I'd like to very
much cheat on my wife.
On the other hand,
I've got this moral calculus that stops
me from doing the net effect is that I
might actually not do it.
So this speaks to a really important
point,
which is the fact that you explain
something from an evolutionary
perspective doesn't mean that it is
biologically fatalistic.
Got It.
Alright.
So homosexuality,
yes.
Now if we add that into this mix that
you're talking about here.
So the top theory that has been proposed
that has not the data has not
cooperated,
comes from actually kin selection.
So let me explain this a bit technical
so you could increase your fitness,
in other words,
you could,
you could extend your genes through
direct reproduction.
That's called direct fitness,
right?
If I have children,
I'm extending my genes,
but I could also,
if you like,
increase my inclusive fitness by
investing in those who are related to
me.
When I.
When I invest in my nephews,
I am indirectly extending my jeans.
Correct.
So the argument then is that a
homosexuality need not be a Darwinian.
Could the sock meaning a Darwinian dead
end?
Because even though you may decide to
not have children by investing in your
kin,
you could still be extending your genes.
Now,
how would you test this idea while you
would take,
for example,
homosexual uncles and heterosexual
uncles and see if the homosexual uncles
invest more in their nephews and nieces?
And if the answer would be yes,
then that would be one data point that
supports the idea.
I have taught my nephew everything I
know about star wars and I am very knows
every year,
but the data has not supported that.
So the bottom line is the top argument,
the top evolution,
if the data has not said that that
actually happened exactly,
and always the that kin selection based
argument for homosexuality,
while at the theoretical level,
conceptually speaking,
sounds good.
The data has not supported that.
So that's as far as I know about the
nexus between homosexuality and
evolution,
although I think we might have mentioned
this when you came on my show,
I do have a current doctoral student who
was actually planning on studying in his
doctoral dissertation,
the intersection between now get ready
for this homosexuality,
evolutionary psychology and consumer
behavior and how's that gonna work?
So we're going to look at phenomena that
typically happen between men and women.
For example,
if you go out on a first date,
uh,
the best way to never have a second date
and the heterosexual context is for a
man to be cheap on a first date,
right?
That guarantee.
And at the end,
even if the woman is a billionaire,
if he exhibits cues of frugality,
it's dead.
Yeah.
Okay.
So then let's take this idea and see
whether within the context of the
dynamics of homosexual relationship,
when two men go out on a date for the
first time,
could we see a replication of this
phenomenon?
But now there isn't male female here.
So what would be the proxy measure?
Top bottom.
So could,
for example,
your sex role as either a predominantly
top or predominantly bottom replicate
the sex differences that we typically
see the interactions between men and
women.
What do you think of that by the way?
Well,
I don't know.
It's so interesting because I don't know
that your sexual position has anything
to do with how you necessarily on a date
would say I'm going to pay or not pay.
I don't know.
I,
I get,
I get this.
You were saying that basically the top
thing that the masculine,
I guess,
I mean,
I guess it's something that's what I
would've guessed that,
but I don't know that we're going to
test something.
Let's take another example of exactly
this idea.
Uh,
so when,
when men and women mate,
there's what's called assortative
mating.
So birds of a feather flock together.
So typically women,
it's not that women want necessarily
tall guys,
is that they want a taller guy,
so it just,
it's very rare for a woman to date
someone shorter than her.
So there's actually a study that was
done with 720 naturally occurring
couples,
only one of the seven slash 20 was the
woman taller than the men really quick.
It's extraordinarily rare.
So let's now let's apply that to almost
now I haven't done the research,
but here's my hypothesis.
I bet that the top bottom distinction
will determine the height thing.
In other words,
if the bottom guy will be in a longterm
union and the not a meeting and the,
the gay sauna for quick sex,
but longterm paragon know a marriage,
uh,
he'll be the shorter guy.
So a lot of the phenomena that we would
pick up from evolutionary psychology as
applied to heterosexual context will
replicate in the homosexual contexts.
So I'm curious with all this being said,
and as you said,
you're,
you're hypothesizing about some of this
stuff and obviously your,
your students going to work on some of
this and other people are going to.
Is there a complication that links
everything else we've been talking about
where if you talk about gay anything
that this could get you in some sort of
trouble?
I don't since you feel that as you're
talking about it,
but that there would be some piece of
this that you might find something that
would lead you to somewhere
uncomfortable or something in the
context of academia.
Yeah.
I don't mean you personally well,
but I actually think that if you do any
research right now on any of the Lgbtq
things,
that would be a very good thing because
it would be somehow label as a
progressive.
So in the context of the els that you
came to a conclusion that was not
politically correct.
Yes.
So that speaks to actually an issue that
I've discussed with several folks and I
think perhaps maybe Sam Harris mentioned
that when he had me on his show,
he was asking me,
is there any research that you were
concerned I wanted to ask you this very
same,
uh,
so maybe we can get into that at and the
term that I had used with him then,
which came from a paper that was
published in nature.
Forbidden Knowledge.
No,
I am a strong non proponent of the idea
of forbidden knowledge.
If research is done honestly said you
Asley with a full adherence to the
scientific method,
then there is no question that is taboo
to ask.
That actually speaks to something in
philosophy.
The difference between deontological
ethics and consequentialist ethics,
the anthological ethics is the
following.
It is never okay to lie.
That's a deal.
Anthological statement.
A consequentialist ethics statement
would say,
well it might be okay to lie the pending
on the consequences of the lot.
Right?
Right.
If it's going to cause 20 people to die.
Exactly.
So one is an absolute as perspective one
is,
it's a situation on.
Depends on the consequences,
so I will use that framework to answer
the forbidden taboo question of what
kind of research is okay or not.
If you are a purist at the ontological,
epistemological person,
I do research wherever it takes me,
then you don't care about the
consequences.
If you are a consequentialist bent,
then you say,
well,
but if we do race differences and the
results come out in a way that it could
be used to harm a racial group,
then we should stay away from it.
I actually think that that's a
profoundly dangerous position to take
because it's precisely this type of
argument that led the social sciences to
reject biology as being important.
The,
the,
the early anthropologist cultural
anthropologist who said biology,
it doesn't matter for humans were coming
from an honorable place because they saw
how cretins could misuse biology,
right?
The Nazis can say,
hey,
there's a battle between the races.
It's a Darwinian struggle.
We're area and we won.
Who Cares?
Let the Jews die.
Uh,
the British social class Aletha said
there is a battle between the social
classes,
the lower classes last,
screw them.
It's a Darwinian struggle,
of course this has nothing to do with
Darwin,
but because these folks misappropriate
misappropriated biological thinking than
the cultural anthropologists came along
and said,
let's get rid of biology because then
nobody can misuse it and now we're in
the quagmire where we are today where we
have to appear in front of the Canadian
Senate to argue that there is such a
thing as male or female.
So No,
if you are a purist,
you pursue knowledge wherever it takes
you unencumbered by the consequences is
the problem that I suppose a certain
amount of people,
scientists included probably think that
they're a purist but actually aren't.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so,
so Mengele probably thought that,
you know,
who is doing all sorts of eof all Nazi
on.
We're not.
In this particular case,
I feel that Nazi references out is
actually sensible as opposed to Nazi
references that are thrown around all
day long.
But.
But if you think about that,
I mean Mengele was doing horrific
experiments on twins and just all sorts
of things that were considered a beyond
imagination.
Horrible.
I'm probably believed that he was doing
it for the good of truth and the good of
science and all that.
I don't.
You know what I mean?
I'm sure he may have been a horrific
person.
I don't think he in his heart.
He probably thought he was doing good
though,
which is so.
The only thing that I would say that
would stop that from happening now is
that we do have institutional review
boards or ethics boards now that ensure
that there is a boundary on the
scientific pursuits that you could
pursue,
and that is,
you know,
you can't frivolously harm animals.
The way you treat them in the lab is
important.
You can't frivolously harm both
physically and slash or psychologically
human subjects right by incident.
Interestingly though,
now they've gone overboard,
so the,
the institutional review boards now have
become so aware to want to be the
emphasis of Mandalay.
So that now if I asked you what is your
sex right?
So that could be traumatizing.
If I asked you what is your income?
Well wait,
in some cultures that's an upfront and
that could send the person into a
tailspin of suicide because I asked him
what his income is and so now the most
banal,
innocuous questions have to be discussed
for 73,000
years and these institutional review
boards,
so I think the fulcrum now swung too far
the other way so that it is now stopping
good science from being done because we
are so afraid of harming any third
party.
So the good intention of we actually
don't want to harm this animal or we
don't want to inject a dye into a humans
either.
My blind them has become now we don't
want to offend this person.
Exactly right.
This is a huge jump.
That's dangerous for science.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and frankly,
I see the fear and my graduate students
when they're about to apply for a thesis
grant because they've heard all these
horror stories that they come to me as
professor side.
How long has the process of going
through today?
And I always answered them.
It really depends on the makeup of the
folks that are going to review your
application.
If they are perfectly reasonable people,
it might go through an a session,
if they are absolute maniacs,
it might take us three months of
rewriting this damn thing for some guy
to finally accept that,
you know,
we're not injecting dye and people's
fear and the reality is most of the
research that I get involved in,
although it's very rigorous and
scientific really has no downstream harm
that's going to be caused,
but it's unbelievable the types of
concerns that people raised and,
and we need to rail the reign that in a
bit.
Yeah.
Uh,
I want to talk a little bit about
robotics,
which I've never even mentioned the
phrase robot to you or any of that
stuff,
but there is something about,
we're,
we're getting into this time with
incredible automation and we know about,
you know,
cars that are driving themselves and we
know that,
uh,
you know,
people ipads are going to put Mcdonald's
employees out of business and all of
this stuff.
How will that affect the way we evolve?
How do now that we're going to add this
thing that is completely artificial and
outside of us?
Is there an evolutionary piece to that
or is that something else all together?
It's something because for evolution to
work right there,
there has to be a selection environment
that is if,
if I'm bored,
let me for.
For for your viewers who may not know
how evolution works,
let me explain in three seconds.
Okay.
Let's use a male and a female.
Get together through sexual
reproduction.
They have an offspring.
This random combination and shuffling of
genes,
results in their offspring.
Having a blue.here,
if that blue.is
heritable,
it can be passed on and if that bluedoff
confers a survival advantage to the
animal,
then the selection pressures are in
place for eventually that blue.to
become part of the makeup of that
species.
So to answer your question,
you would have to explain to me how
there are specific selection pressures
that affect the survivability of an
organism or it's reproductive viability
for me to be able to offer an evolution
argument right now.
I can't think of one.
Does that make sense?
That does make sense.
I feel I can't end this on a question
that we would say doesn't make sense
perfectly,
so I will ask you this and we're going
to do this many more times.
You'll do this again anytime I'm here.
Alright.
I'm taking everything that we've
discussed here.
Are you hopeful or not for the future of
the West?
Do you think we are just caught in sort
of this leftist,
postmodern is stuff versus a nationalism
or populism that could be dangerous or
do you think that the enlightenment
values that you care about and
liberalism and all that actually has a
chance to turn this stuff around is not
where I need to put on my marketing hat
on?
Yeah,
as an sell it brother.
Exactly.
So if I'm going to speak about some of
the times when I see the tsunami of
ostrich thinking that comes my way,
then I feel very pessimistic.
I feel as though an utter disaster has
to happen before people wake up.
On the other hand,
because I'd like to peddle hope and
market hope.
I think that it doesn't take too much to
redress the ship if enough silent
people,
silent voices rise up in every ecosystem
on facebook,
on the,
in the media,
in academia,
at the bar,
and actually the,
you know,
trigger the courage that is necessary
for them to weigh in.
I think that the voices,
the enemies of reason will become
marginalized,
but we need to rise up and that's why I
always tell people when they asked me,
well,
what can I do?
I said,
well,
you don't have to have the voice of Dave
Rubin or the platform if they ruin.
You just have to have enough courage to
take on your friends when you're
engaging them on facebook.
When your professor says something that
seems like it's an affront to reason
challenge,
him or her don't be silent.
So I think that if enough people do
that,
then the ship can be addressed.
If we remain apathetic,
then I think we will lose the I.
I totally agree.
And as I always say,
I'm one guy that started a channel on
Youtube.
You're one guy who started a channel on
We came from very different places and
and if our voices have done a little
something,
then there's plenty of other people that
can replicate that and brother as well.
All right.
I think you guys know where his channel
is,
but if not,
check out gads youtube channel a youtube
at youtube.com/headset.